[Music]
hey what's up we are back um we have a
very special segment here I asked my
friend George camel who's got a new book
coming out about finance and the chaos
and the nonsense that we're seeing all
over the place about it's the end of
time and the Dollar's going away and you
should have a side hustle oh you should
probably should have a side but you
should have a passive in just all the
stupid stuff so I asked my friend George
I like hey man come on to the show with
me and a I want to introduce you to our
gang but B I want to behind the curtains
look at you the author of this thing
what in the world is happening with
their money and by the way George is
somebody that uh I call on the weekends
and I'll say hey man I'm about to move
this money over here what do you think
about this fund and he'll say yeah
absolutely do that or don't do that so
he's somebody that I trust with me and
my family's money so I'm excited to have
him on we're going to just do a segment
with him and uh I think you're going to
get a ton of value and he's hilarious
and he loves telling everybody that
we're best friends and we are not just
kidding we kind of are not really not
even close but we did go to the blink182
show and had to push his Tesla down the
highway when it ran out of bad please
welcome George
camel what's up man hey thanks for
having me on it's good this is our first
time for me I'm kind of nervous I've
never been on the John deloney show
we've done a lot together but not in
your territory why why does it make you
nervous uh I just feel like I'm not in
control uh that's probably a whenever we
do things see someone for that we try
I've been telling you for a while you
should
um man yeah I guess youve never you
never been on ever no youve never
invited me I didn't want to remind you
here but now better time no better time
than the present but it's an honor I'm a
big fan and it's nice to be like inside
of the show you're not a fan you never
listened to my show one time I listen
you've never listened one time it's fine
like we work together you hear me run my
mouth all the time but I usually I need
to watch Comedy to make you know what I
mean I'm looking for
uppers sometimes the show's heavy be
little and we take enough of that on the
Ramy show together so I get my dose
Downy I get my dose of my Downer
yeah but I I do I do love a gift George
is a gift you just had a baby yes first
kid tell me about it how's it been it's
been hard I will say that harder than I
thought it would be Whitney had a really
hard pregnancy and the delivery was
great and healthy that was all great but
then she got mastitis and that turns
into scarlet fever which I didn't know
existed in today's world and that turned
into an abscess and like a minor surgery
and then the baby got the tongue tie
thing and so there was always just
another like hard thing yeah in an
already hard season where you're like
not sleeping you're in kind of teammate
mode instead of marriage mode it's just
like survival mode yeah I like did you
get the thing you get the hatchet I'll
get the Roe you get the dogs I'll get
the baby who's dropping the you know
what I mean it's just a lot of logistics
and not a lot of connection uh and in
between there's some really sweet
moments you know with the baby and all
that but it has been dramatically more
difficult than I thought and so I have a
new found respect for parents I used to
like dog parents and be like you know me
I'd be like I'm a dog Dad I know how
hard it is and I I ate I wasn't going to
say that you and I have had that
conversation you're like John I've got
I've got two French Bulldogs yeah God
fed me some Humble Pie you're in the
middle of um you're releasing your first
book which is chaos right and you're
hosting your own show and two other
shows right so I mean like bananas right
um You and I are heading off on a
speaking event coming up like so it's
it's it would be chaotic for any person
on the planet then you throw a newborn
in there and then you throw a very
difficult first few months with the
health with your wife all the chaos that
goes with that um there's something
about I don't feel like anything I don't
feel at all I'm just going to keep doing
the next right thing I'm going to do
this thing I'm going to make sure I fill
in the blank I'm going to make sure I
exercise which I know you don't do I'm
going to make sure I I do this which
what but I'm going to keep doing those
things and I'm going to March along even
though I don't feel like it and well now
it's the time where it's easiest to veg
out and stare at the screens and play a
stupid game on your phone instead of
doing the hard thing like you talk about
the daily choices the worst yeah
yeah yeah like if I had slept good maybe
I would work out today John but I didn't
sleep good so therefore you know what I
mean just doing it out of discipline and
sheer habit is just so hard wor but it's
on the other side your your daughter
will wake up at 1 your old or nine
months and she'll look at you and then
you'll have yeah that's probably a good
way to think of it you're going to be
she's going to be one regardless
regardless and the choice you get to
make is how will I have shown up for her
when she turns one when when that light
bulb comes on and it comes on before one
but when that light bulb comes
on will I be all in or will I be a ghost
of who I was shell of who I used to be
right well truthfully that's been the
biggest struggle in our marriage right
now is Whitney being like hey look her
in the eyes like be present with her
don't veg out on your phone while
feeding you know what I mean that's been
difficult for me after a long day work
and you just want you know you want to
veg out but you're like I have I need to
connect with this baby like that's
what's important to me I know I should
do it but my brain is is occupado yeah
or I don't know how it's it's a tool set
it's hard I I'm used to having
conversation let's have some wit and
banter with a baby you know I'm making
sounds I'm singing I'm doing all the
things I know how to do to see what she
reacts to which is fun so you've got
uh you sat down in a room over the last
year and wrote a
book about
what well it was a tough task to write a
money book at Ramsey Solutions there's
this elephant in the room um you know
big shoes to fill when you have The
Total Money Makeover the bestselling
personal finance book of all time and
you're like I'm going to write something
different and better some you know what
I mean like I have big shoes to fill cuz
the feet are still in those shoes
exactly it's still sold in the same book
goal was not to like rewrite The Total
Money Makeover the goal was to write a
book that feels like I'm speaking to
everyone in current times of like this
is what the current state of personal
finance is here's the real problems
America's facing here's why people are
saying they can't get ahead and here's
what I know to be true and so it was a
lot of you know I start with my story of
how I started broke with my I didn't
come from money my parents were
immigrants I was $40,000 in debt and
over a decade of just hard work and
following a proven plan
my wife and I are now net worth
Millionaires and it's not to brag it's
to say if an average George can do it
you can too but here's what it takes the
gap between financial peace between
Financial stress and financial peace is
littered with myths and distractions and
traps and noise so my goal was to cut
through all of that and tell people the
truth about the financial system
designed to keep them broke so the truth
about credit scores and credit cards and
student loans and auto loans and
mortgage traps and investing traps and
marketing and consumerism so that they
can break free from this Matrix that
they find themselves in and some for a
lot of people become self-aware for the
first time that they're even in this
Matrix like this is a simulation bro you
got you can opt out and they go what do
you mean I don't have need I don't need
a credit score that's jarring to a lot
of people and so I walk it very
carefully because I know what I'm saying
is sounds insane to someone who's been
in it their whole life like I was but to
deprogram that to break free from that
and achieve all of your financial goals
and become the person you want to be and
to give the way want to give that's what
the book's all about it's not really
about the money we have to talk about
money so we can stop talking about money
gotcha gotcha well H how do
you I feel like there's two different
competing anxieties here the anxiety
that you and I talk about all the time
which is your body knows that you owe
somebody money they're your master they
own you right
and like if you don't do XY or Z they
take your house they take your car they
take your food and your body knows I'm
not safe in that situation regardless of
how good the deal is there's also this
competing anxiety which is this inner
desire to connect other people to be a
part of a tribe and the entire culture
says if you don't have a new car we you
and I were in a conversation the other
day with somebody like well what do you
want me to get a car with 100,000 miles
on it and we're like we both have that
yeah what are you talking about and it
was like you're not St that guy wasn't
stupid a guy wasn't entitled that guy I
believed a story that he been told which
is if you have a car that has more than
a 100,000 miles you are being unsafe to
you and your family right if you don't
have a house with every kid with their
own room and their own bathroom you're
failing your
children so I I I have to compete here
right one of these is all right I know
my body needs safety the other is I
don't want to be the only one right I
don't want to be the only person not
doing these things what do you tell
somebody that says I I I can't op
operate outside of this world well
number one are they open to new
information cuz if they're not it's it's
a pointless conversation there you go so
you have to go like hey my way isn't
working I'm curious to know how this way
works because that sounds more peaceful
the goal of this book when it comes to
helping people avoid some of those traps
and I point out the Three Stooges of
wealth building is what I call it but I
think it applies in life and I'm sure
this applies to mental health Pride fear
and greed those are the three traps I
find when people are trying to build
wealth but also when it comes to
personal finance they go yeah but I'm
smarter than that I'm going to be the
guy who pays off the credit card every
month and doesn't pay interest great the
credit the credit card company loves
that you believe that that's you winning
is that you're not paying interest and
that somehow your life is going to be
great and you're going to build wealth
uh fear is a big one uh fear there's a
scarcity mindset that we see a lot of
people I never had money so I need to
keep stacking even when you're doing
well there's like this never ending
Chase for the goalpost has kept moving
well we have a million but really we
need two million now because we factor
in inflation so we need four million
when you and so it never ends there
never stops yeah and then you have greed
which is I want to make a million
dollars in the next five years and if I
don't and crypto is the answer because I
can't wait for a mutual fund to grow in
a retirement account and so there's this
element of I can do it faster and I'm
smarter and pride fear and greed I found
is what causes people to fall right on
their face and it's one of the reasons
we have to have the nice car because our
can't swallow your pride and drive a
beater next to your cooworker who's
leasing the luxury vehicle it's
embarrassing that's the lease is making
the car company very wealthy and they
want you to think it's I I just bought a
car with cash and the finance office
called me and they're like we're really
concerned Why aren't you financing this
she was like well you should lease it
that's that's what I do it's the smart
way to do it I'm like I don't know how
to tell you this like I had to be like
listen I host a show where I tell people
not to lease cars that it's the
stupidest way and so I in all the
kindness but it just made me remember
how how much work we have to do to
untrain people's brains to go like there
is a different way and there's a better
way there's just so much pain out there
and we take the brunt of the calls where
like life didn't happen the way it
looked on paper yeah like well if I do
this deal on Airbnb I'm going to make so
much money and they call and they go
like we can't afford the payment and the
tenants screwed up our house and the car
is getting repoed and we're on the other
end trying to help them pick up the
pieces and it's one of the reasons we're
just like debt equals R less debt equals
less risk don't owe anyone money your
life's probably going to be less
stressful the the hardest challenge I
think is that I wrestle with in the
conversations we have about money is
when I talk to
somebody most of the people we talk to
have never been on the other side so I
I've been to your house and
um you have a very very nice home in an
extraordinary neighborhood and you could
go to the bank today and probably qualif
ify for four or 5x the home you're in
right now does that weigh on you at
all no and I think it reminds me of uh
Dave was on our friend Graham Stefan
show and they asked him like if you
could borrow a million dollars in
guarantee that you would get aund this
much return would you and Dave was like
no they're like why we just told you
you're guaranteed to make this money and
he was like I don't borrow money and it
was such a like mic drop you know bad a
moment of Dave just being like
I actually live by a set of values and
principles MH to where I'm not star eyed
but what by what could be and what the
bank could give me and what investments
could make he's at peace with where he's
at and so confident in his plan to build
wealth that nothing could sway him and
to me that is like in invincibility and
so that's what I feel being anchored
into a value yeah on a much smaller
scale because my wealth is minuscule
compared to De Ramsey's but there's such
an amazing feeling going like my next
home I'm sure will move one day into a
bigger nicer home maybe we're going to
pay cash for it yeah and that means it's
not going to be a home that is 4X what
we cuz it's going to take a while to do
that with at the speed of cash but what
I will have is peace and the muscle to
save to where I'm like if we need to
save for anything it's not going to be a
problem like saving for a $220,000
vacation or like save for pay someone's
adoption fees it's just going to be
another little goal we go yeah we know
how to do that but someone who's never
done that they can't fathom even saving
up $10,000 to pay for a car what they
can fathom is paying $400 a month for
the car payment so it's it's a shift
mentally you got to make you host
multiple shows you're a public figure
you travel the country speaking at
events all over the place
um and this morning I had to run to
Walmart to get something and talk to the
person who's stocking shelves in the
morning they're like that's cute bro
like cool like P off your car P off your
house real real cool um I work at
Walmart cuz I have to and my dad left
this happened this happened this is the
job I could get I make $18 an hour um
and I'm really grateful to have it this
kind of book works for y'all um I
appreciate it man but I'm trying to make
groceries and I got to get a car like
talk to that guy well I have deep
empathy for those that
feel like there's a certain kind of
person that can get ahead with money and
it's not me cuz I remember feeling that
way I thought you were born into wealth
or you just never have it yeah and
wealth is a very generic term to me
wealth just is is freedom yeah do you
have options do you have margin in your
life that's a good point because wealth
to me means more than I've got right now
yeah know what I mean because I'm always
chasing a feeling wealth to the person
at Walmart is if I could make $20 an
hour it would blow my mind yeah and the
goal poost always moves when you make 20
it's like wealth is now 25 an hour it's
it's always more than I got instead of
saying no I'm I'm at peace yeah that's a
good point the hard thing for those
people out there who feel like this
isn't for me this plan that's nice but
I'm too broke for this or I'm too
wealthy for this there's this like
everyone says this is not for me the day
you realize you're not special in the
best way yeah yes you're uniquely made
by by the Creator but I'm not special as
far as this plan not working for me to
math to math and so here's the the best
thing I can say to that person is that
it's not all your fault but it's your
responsibility okay and that's a tough
pill to swallow not by your hand but in
your lap yes and so in parenthesis not
all your fault we have to own the
choices that we've made that have got us
here uh even if those choices are I saw
my mom and dad handle money the wrong
way and I fell for that I thought my
parents were going to pay for college
and it turned out to be student loans in
my name we hear those stories all the
time but the decision you have to make
is I have agency and autonomy over my
life most people feel like life is just
happening to me and I got to do whatever
the lenders say and I got to do whatever
my boss says but when you realize I have
control not just when it comes to like
what I do with that paycheck but what
career path I choose and how much effort
I'm going to put in and what
opportunities I say yes or no to and the
decisions I make or don't make when it
comes to those dollars and who I decide
to hang out with when you start to
control those inputs you get this little
thing called hope where you're just like
oh if I can dial down the noise of the
social media gurus or if I can believe
that man if I just go learn on YouTu
learn the skill I can go apply for that
job and make double what I'm making now
yeah but people have just had the belief
beat out of them they're just hopeless
they're cynical and they think like this
is the world we live in the economy it's
the Boomers and I talk about that in in
the first chapter of the book I lay out
every single objection and excuse that
we could point fingers at and it feels
good it felt good to write it it was
cathartic I was like yeah man the
housing Market's insane and college
tuition's out of control and the fed and
Congress and the guy in the White House
and it at the end of the day it was just
when I point back at me it was like oh
gosh not me not me not me back to the
other stuff right right it's not fun to
pull up that Financial mirror to go like
okay even if you're not the entire
problem you are the entire solution yeah
and we know that like forgiveness from
the government is probably not going to
happen like inflation is not a dial I
can control but what I can control is
I'm going to do that side hustle to get
out of debt for the next two years yeah
and then I'm going to bust my butt and
save up and I'm going to get married and
we're going to combine finances and now
we have two incomes and we're going to
make a little more progress and a little
more progress and it might take you a
decade and you wanted it to take a year
and we know most people they
overestimate what they can accomplish in
a year underestimate what they can
accomplish in a decade that was my story
yep didn't happen overnight it took 10
years for some people it'll take 20 yep
that's okay run your own race because
when you run other people's race there's
no Finish Line that's the problem with
this kind of comparison mindset of like
well John's you see the kind of car he
has and the kind of house he has dude
like he doesn't pay your bills right you
don't know what he's going through and
so it gave me great peace and for that
person who's feels stuck to just go all
right I'm not going to compare myself
I'm going to tunnel vision and go what
is the right Next Step for me and I I
think that's the reason that's so
important is um strangely and it's weird
to admit this I when I spent all those
years working in higher education with
the with students it was the
conversation was so much in my lap what
can I solve for them um bring me your
challenges and I'll solve them for you
and there is a part of that right part
of my job was to teach them what options
were and not make that happen but it was
it was an eye openening moment for me a
few years ago when I was sitting
somewhere saying hey every time I've sat
down with a family who's about to lose a
child every time I've sat down with
someone who just lost a loved one every
time I've sat down with somebody who was
marginalized because of Any number of
reasons societies kick them to the
margins so we don't want you
here we I always sit in those moments
and they're heavy and they're dark and
they are filled with tears and it could
be two hours it could be two months it
could be two years of conversations we
always land on the same question what
are you going to do now and it was when
I sat here with this money thing because
I was always for 20 years I've been
wondering what Washington's going to do
about this stuff and I knew I know Dave
Ramsey principles and all but I kept
saying what's the right monetary policy
and what's this and this you were coming
at it intellectually right instead of
looking in the mirror going okay dude
this is the way this is right now what
are we going to do the house is on fire
and it's like sitting there and watching
it burn and being like when is the fire
department getting here at some point
you got to go hey they're not coming
they're not coming or they're going to
get here it's going to be too late get
the family out of here let's get all our
our stuff out of here and so I think
it's important for people to know in
this book you a walk
through we call them traps and stuff and
you and I laugh about it because we live
in this world but I think it's like I
have family members that genuinely had
never heard that a credit score is a
scam they didn't know that that
generally did thought they were missing
something when they didn't understand
crypto like I'm behind or that they
don't have a rental property that they
have are 100% leveraged on so they feel
behind and they're just screwed yeah
they feel completely host and so a you
walk through all these excus all all the
things that were told that aren't true
and then you walk through what I think
is more important is a plan here's what
you do man and I wish it was more
complicated than that here's a plan and
it's not hard it's hard but it's not
hard right simple but not not hard right
yeah and in chapter nine is where we
move from the system to Breaking Free
from the system so it's chained to the
system here's all the things that you're
chained to and then I'm going to show
you how to break free and so I talk
about budgeting is freedom spending is
self-control margin is breathing room
savings is peace debt is a thief wealth
is patience and my favorite is
generosity is joy yeah is what the whole
thing kind of points to and in the book
like the fruits of the spirit is the
verse I use on the on the flap on the
title page because truthfully I feel
like that's what we're all striving for
we want peace and joy and self-control
that's what we're aiming at and money is
just an obstacle instead of a tool to
help us get there so if we can remove
that obstacle and transform it into a
tool to where we go we don't have to
worry about money we got time now we can
connect with our we can build those
relationships that were broken and you
also loosen the chains
of your employer running your life other
companies running your life even in some
ways not legally but the government
running you're like like we're going to
raise interest okay I don't borrow money
so when you don't yeah when Dave Ramsey
has a 0% interest rate because he
doesn't have a mortgage right he's not
as concerned or when they say what's
your credit score he's like I don't I
haven't looked at 30 years I don't know
and I just don't care right finally we
have to solve this important thing and
then we got to
go there's a Reddit Thread about this is
a great conspiracy across the country we
need to clear up let's do
it are we actually friends oh
gosh I ask myself every day honestly I
think it
changes I think we it's one of those we
love each other we don't like each other
I don't love you I think I like you but
I don't would go far you like me I love
you that causes some tens causes a lot
of yeah on the show and here's the
backstory uh John is mean to me I'm
going to put that in air quotes
cuz I've actually been bullied and uh in
in my previous life when I was a kid
what Jon does I is a defense mechanism
that I see through instantly oh okay you
see me as a threat that is correct my
masculinity is a threat to your
masculinity well you have a perfectly
groomed beard and I just can't grow
facial hair so instantly I'm waiting for
you to just come out with this you have
uh you have biohacked your eyes with
these devices called glasses I don't
have those I just you have perfect
vision fine I I have blurry vision it's
fine f wait the truth is uh I think I'm
your friend I'm your friend I think
you're my friend we text each other
outside of work you send me articles
that you find interesting I pushed your
Tesla down the highway when it ran out
of batteries that's a true friend that's
what friends do so on the show we're not
good at showing it truthfully you know
what I mean I like it we're not good at
showing each other affection live on air
but I like it that way and it's kind of
a bit too like when I'm like I'm here
with my best friend in the whole world
John deloney and you're like we're not
friends exactly that to me is a bit and
uh but they don't get to see us at the
blink182 show singing our hearts out
rocking out together see so I think that
I think that squelches it oh we're going
to edit that part out we're not going to
let this part go live okay cool hey
Breaking Free from broke George
campell's new book thanks for writing
this thanks for the support man you are
you get mentioned at least three times
and I apologize I do call you a mediocre
guitar player in the book I think
mediocre is um but it's compared to
slash it's very generous it's compared
to SL I'm not even mediocre but I do
have some great quotes from you that are
very helpful and there's so much that
aligns when it comes to what you're
doing and what I'm doing in the money
space we both want people to solve for
free
and I know this book is going to help
you do that with finances so thanks for
helping me spread the word you're
awesome BR thanks great friend
and I agree to
disagree